Contraception, with a variety of methods
available many people are able to avoid
unintended pregnancies.  But what happens
when things don't go quite as planned?
Thanks to modern science a second chance
is possible.  So how does emergency
contraception or "plan-b" work?  And what
exactly is happening inside the female
body? During the female menstrual
cycle many hormones are released
beginning a chain reaction.  The pituitary
gland in the brain releases FSH
which stimulates the growth of follicles
and a premature egg in the ovaries.
These follicles then release
estrogen
which helps prepare the uterus lining
and triggers the brain to release leutinizing
hormone or LH.  LH then
triggers ovulation in which the egg is
released into the fallopian tubes where it
will spend around twelve to twenty-four
hours waiting to be fertilized.  If the
egg isn't fertilized in this time it
begins to dissolve and is shed away with
the uterine lining during menstruation.
Though this window of opportunity is brief
it's increased by the fact that sperm
can live for up to five days.
So the keen sperm from days ago show up early to the show anxiously awaiting
ovulation.
Birth control pills taken on a regular
basis modify these hormone levels.  By
increasing progestin levels the body
thinks it's already released an egg or
already pregnant.
It effectively decreases FSH and LH and the cycle halts.  But in the case
of emergency contraception which is only
taken if regular contraception methods
fail,
a few different mechanisms take place.
The most important thing to understand
is that fertilization doesn't happen
immediately or even within hours after
intercourse.  Instead the sperm must
undergo a few biological changes in the
fallopian tube first which takes time.  This is why emergency contraception is
still possible the morning after.
It can actually work up to five days
after intercourse.  If taken during the
first half of the menstrual cycle,
emergency contraception works
specifically to prevent ovulation.
This way the egg is not released even
though it may be ready and the available
sperm cannot fertilize it.
In cases where it's too late to inhibit ovulation
emergency contraception is thought to
also thicken cervical mucus trapping sperm.
As well, it may directly inhibit
fertilization between sperm and egg.
Clinical studies show that emergency
contraception prevents pregnancy
before fertilization.  No studies have
shown an effect from emergency
contraception if fertilization has
already occurred.  It does not stop
implantation from happening nor does it
have any effect after implantation has
occurred.
In this way, its unable to cause an abortion.
And while there are some minor side effects to
these drugs, such as nausea and headaches,
scientific studies have demonstrated its
safety in women of all ages and found
that the benefits far outweigh any risks.
Got of burning question you want answered?
Ask it in the comments or on facebook and twitter, and subscribe for more weekly science videos.